hey what's up guys welcome to this
week's YouTube video and I've got an
amazing guy on the show he is a from
Birmingham he's developed by he's did
some amazing projects he's 30 years old
and he got started via letting less
having a little agent I went to rent
business and now he's in development
absolutely crushing it Anthony
welcome to the show bro hey thanks for
thanks for having me I appreciate me now
from Birmingham so talk to me about what
you do right now you're 30 years old and
you caught my attention because you're
literally doing multi-million pound
pickups that's incredible bro like what
stuff you working on very just student
accommodation : projects well I'm
talking on a big we're not talking in a
full bed hours that you've spent into a
6 bed house no no no so they you know
ranging from 50 beds up to 250 plus beds
and blocks or you know that gdv is 5
million up to 25 plus million sort of
sizable deals again it's relative its
relative as a as sometimes when people
say this to me I also retort and say you
know it's fairly relative because as
some of the deals I've got the smaller
deals and the student accommodation
deals certain institutional funds or
whoever wouldn't touch them because
they're too small yeah so it's it's all
it's all relative you mean some
companies would say that I say only that
you're working on payments some of the
deals are just nothing they wouldn't
touch it yes it's too small yeah and
other people or companies ago asked that
big deal yeah so it's relative isn't it
I'd love to pick your brain and hear
about what deals looks like you're
working on fine and how you find them
and stuff yeah why don't we start from
the beginning because you started just
like just like myself in any of us with
not a silver spoon born in the mouth
yeah and you started out having to real
hustle hard right so talk to us about
that and yeah so started with why
essentially - I was a student so I guess
I've got student debt so I guess that's
effectively
- it's like the lateness company I was a
student at University University of
Leicester I were on a viewing of a
landlord and realized the landlord
had other prophecies I then contacted
the landlord after the viewing as they
had slipped me that number very cheaply
during the viewing contacted or
contacted her afterwards and said you
know I can find your students I can fly
like a tenant fine service if you pay me
I'll let you have a properties for you
she said yes and then I started calling
number landlords and cold calling them
and saying the same thing basically I'm
Anthony I'm from the at that point I was
a treasurer for the management Society
at the University started and I'm
Anthony I'm quoting from magnet aside
said this see straight why though right
why you flipping the card zipping it
credibility yeah but you're taking
something that isn't anything it's
nothing at all it's nothing and then
you're turning into something where that
sounds like it suddenly got clouds yeah
where did you learn that skill is just
instinct instinct yeah I don't think
it's anything to know but it is because
being able to be able to say oh I'm
calling for and and and get an in with a
nothing but that's that was the first
thing that he did it was also people
recognized brands or companies and quite
large thank you so associating outlining
or identifying the computer you can
associate yourself with an individual
that you can legitimately yourselves
just associate yourself but if it's only
going to add to your that's what that's
what you're doing right now right yeah
I'll be here
oh there you go brand Association so its
massive I'm so I guess that was just
instinctively I thought well if I
mention this and it was true yeah part
of the management Society so do you
really mean anything so they would oh
yeah okay and then come up from there so
by the time I graduated so you don't
really make any real money so it's not
at all when I was doing the same thing
because that's exactly what I did but so
your University and then you are renting
out people what rooms
poverty's yeah so landlord you own a
five beds you didn't house yeah it's
available for next year academic and to
you and say are we doing this sorry
we're we're doing this well yeah and
what year my second year of uni 2009 Oh
2010 okay so your management evil prob
renting out rooms basically getting free
education yeah well you learn from other
people's properties oh yeah and when you
in that position so when I started it
was a lat only service and then when I
graduated so a year in a bit later once
I graduate from university I decided to
do it full-time
so getting a job or graduate job or
anything and taken on the extra
potential burden and risks of all these
of additional expenses and getting
emulsion on this other thing in the foot
that me try this business thing out I
already had like an existing client base
I did that full time I started to manage
properties and the rest of it and took
it from there I'm sort of how that's
well how it went
that's awesome so you you're running a
little late an agent say which very
little in my opinion because I did the
same thing right
it's like the best way to learn the
nitty-gritty about property so you're
doing that and then and then what
happens how how did you begin to burrow
because I mean you you you secure a
really juicy went to rent the or didn't
you all right one of the big ones yeah
girls over the years what was the first
way to rent they leave it and how did
that come about
first rent amount deal was I worked to
it so I went to a property networking
event in Birmingham so this is Boston I
graduated a dolphin property me
Burlington property me in Birmingham
yeah I was full-time and property and
decided look I need to get some clients
you know I'm trying to grow my business
it was just me working from home and I
went to property networking event for a
potential you know find some potential
clients there got there there was a guy
talking standing up front scribbling on
some flip chart yeah he was talking
about this you know I I get a property I
rent it from the landlord for 500 pounds
I then rent it out myself for 800 pounds
that make three hundred pounds and I
sort of sat there and it was just like
there's like a bit more than epiphany
because like oh my god yeah this whole
time I've been making little ten percent
management fee and all these tenets felt
fine fees but I can
it means you know making a bigger chunk
of money on a monthly basis so it turns
out I got something different from that
unload something new go into that
networking event and you didn't even
know it was called rent to rent I don't
think they call it rent to it you just
knew the concept I just knew that you
instead of me managing it I get to rent
it from the landlord and make given
given guaranteed way to the landlord
then you rent it out and you were like
boom I can make a lot under make a lot
moment and these are obviously multi
layer properties H was yeah so it's not
50 quid extra so they might have all 500
plus pounds a month so that same night I
emailed a bunch of landlords that same
evening as I got home at documentation
see that's it so I don't I'm gonna need
to sound arrogant but I don't really I
don't really mess about ahead of time
would it be fine wasting time but people
people will think you know okay what
would now say yeah honey now I need to
think about this now let's do a
spreadsheet now I need to go and consult
an accountant and then if some of that
where is the difference between
successful people unsuccessful people
his successful person just does it and
figures out on the job which is a living
testament to your whole business that
you're 30 years old story of my life of
those old try it first yeah I don't I
mean when you look at the downside the
downside is pretty low
the worst it can say is no maybe you
know so what happened is you start
phoning landlords and the messaging my
existence my existing landlords clients
I contacted them set them an email said
about from my own membrane or
mile ago now maybe three yeah three or
four sent an email saying I can make you
pop see from you long term for I can
release it from you for three to five
years and I'll pay you a guaranteed rent
and that's it I'll look after the rest
I've been the tennis so you know you let
me know how you're gonna make money
so I'll write them obviously but the
property out myself and the difference
is mine yeah and so said that and after
you got back to me and said yeah one got
back to me pretty quickly next day and
said yes I'm interested he was a build
of actually he's a pretty big builder
now in one sitting home of the company
they've got a big building company they
build big projects and he owned what he
told me at the time was 20 odd
properties and so this one was sort of a
headache for him and he came out very
quickly and said yep you can lease it
so I'd say electronic so I found a lease
agreement online somewhere probably not
good should have got something for most
of this mm cut line get it done that's
what you do I mean that behind site
it was good to get the deal done but
it's probably not the best move it's
good to get advice or something and then
at least you can repeat your agreement
but we got the agreement on line I don't
did you for that man no but you could
have went wrong but this is this is part
of the as part of the game as Nikia got
it started got it sent it electronically
through documents yeah we're thing he
signed it electronically I've got the
tenants telex were international so I've
got those tenants signed up they were
pretty sure I had stuff at that point
working for me I'm one or two staff
members they were coming from abroad to
live in Leicester to study is when we
found them online so they were lined up
to move into the property so I've got
the landlord that I would agree to lease
the property from just sign this lease
with electronically I've never met any
person by the way I've got allowed not
to meet the tenant at the property with
all the sets of keys and moved a tenant
in and then so it was done so thing is
when you relate an agent you're getting
a percentage of the rent yeah so there's
it's very small but there's no risk but
then when you start doing when two rents
the margins are a lot bigger you can
potentially make a lot more but the the
risk is greater do you think that's the
case in all business do you think the
bigger the reward the bigger the risk
100%
it's part of the you know you can be an
employee working for somebody and yes
you can get a stable income salary and
have a fraction of the rewards of what's
what the business is doing or you go out
by yourself take all the
but take all the reward or if you're
partnering with someone you can share
the reward and share the risk I don't
know that's something you've done a lot
partnered with people yeah yeah so I put
it took me a few years before a partner
to people so especially in the you know
particularly in the deals I'm working on
now the larger stuff as I was one of my
letters coming in a renter when I did
that myself you know I on all of the
business for seven years and by the time
I started working on the larger stuff I
kind of realized actually it'd be good
to partner now because you had a rental
ring didn't you that was making you
about eight and a half thousand pounds
of profit a month yeah but then what
happened to that I had an agreement in
place for that so it was a small student
block in Birmingham has an agreement in
place and as part of the lease agreement
the freeholder through the lease holds a
freeholder had a right to surrender the
lease so that they could break the lease
and dispose of the whole property enough
to pay a fee for that so that's what
happened the property was struggling and
when we took it on we did some work to
it and improved the property got it left
very quickly and it was you know
operating quite well a lot of income was
coming in and so when they saw the
property was based on the internet we
were generating for it and not our lease
okay so the person that came in the
freehold or the new buyer had the
opportunity to keep us as the lease
holder or buy it and get a management
company and and get rid of us and that's
what happened they came in they wanted
us to manage it and I said we don't
manage properties anymore not interested
and I guess that was part of my my sort
of development or progress was that I
focused I decided you know I looked at
my business and it's been like the 80/20
rule but in states when you all worked
out look where's my time best spent
where do I make the most money where do
I get the most bang for my buck if you
like and I worked out management was
just not going to make me any money
lettings and management though rental
rent and the large amounts coming in was
Wells going to really make some
and doing it under bigger property was
making a lot more money yeah so I got to
assay jurors I was handing back manage
properties and I was just refusing
anyone that came along that wants me to
my company to my name's Dale properties
so by that stage and this is how it
worked because but the owner of that
property approached us to manage
actually sorry to let rooms in their
property that block and when I looked it
and I said I you know I worked out that
the amount of time and FM resources to
let that building would be so much that
they couldn't pay us enough that you
just wouldn't be worth it for us so I
offered look take the whole building on
and in return you'll get a fixed fixed
friend and we'll do it we'll do our bit
and that was agreed and I was on you
agreed because I decided to focus if I
wasn't focused and I instead thought you
know that we just managed it I can get
it 39 beds so there's a good amount of
rental income and that management fee
would have still been maybe 40 40 grand
or so a year yes I was a good fee but
it's just outside of my focus yeah so so
what she focus now so you've been late
an idea but to me all this while the
sounds of it that was more for
experienced contacts the well being late
nature it's more because I saw what I
thought was an opportunity to start
business yeah and and then I started
doing it and realized actually this
isn't great for me when I worked as like
an agent I actually worked for free Oh
little early to learn about property
yeah sort of same as you I went to the
prompt to networking events and I just
said if you've got any properties within
this area and you want the rooms running
out or do it for free
Wow I'll charge an admin a small admin
fee to the tenant which you could do
about then sure and but I won't learn
anything and I did it for free just to
number one get in with the landlords and
number two to get an understanding of
what went well and then the market so
then what I was doing that 17 so then
when I came to buy my first house I knew
you know it's straight away ya know has
it taken you know exactly what works I
had a lot can be learned from that
that's really good I think a lot of
people are afraid to do that
because most people want to paycheck
very thin yeah but the moment that you
stop working for a paycheck is the
moment suddenly you become a lot greater
mm-hmm like I bet a lot of the work you
do these days you're getting paid to do
it you're building for something you're
building on a mission you're building or
something bigger you don't get paid
immediately okay pay for the hour
showing into something yeah you know
some of the deals I've got so I'm some
my larger deals I think you only make
the money at the point you realize that
you know whatever deal you've done so
it's only realized once you've actually
sold or and actually rented it out
that's the only time your return is
realized so for me once I've got
planning permission on a large
development site that I can cash out you
know please yeah sometimes you know that
the six-figure sums plus on their deals
that I do so I can potentially cash out
our planning stage and make a lot of
money or I can hold off and go to
development but again it's a lot more
risk just like you what you were sayin
earlier so I can hold off and stay in
for the development take extra risk but
then receive extra what point did you
realize that you wanted to start buying
actual proper buildings big buildings
yeah because that's what you do now
right that rent to rent help that large
one yes I wanna get into that I don't
know if you think I wish I owned it it
was that that one yeah to a degree
well of course yes when the money was
coming in and we didn't need any more
staff to manage it it was all within our
capacity so that came in we didn't need
any actual staff yes it took a bit more
resources in time but then the money was
coming he wants his rented and it's
fully that you've just got to look after
everyone and then when that money was
coming in it was I had gone this
compared to running around 50 different
houses it's a different life yeah
running a an apartment building compared
to running 50 different the apartment
building is a absolute breeze in
comparison but it takes just as much
energy to buy one big property as to buy
one small all right yeah exactly exactly
yeah or even tomorrow it takes way less
energy to manage that big building it
does it does
messenger of saying that when YouTube is
that people are just starting out oh
it's not for them no but here's the
point you built up to that yeah alright
but to start with to buy a development
block you usually mess up when you're on
your first heal I'd rather mess up on a
small the other than a big deal but if
you partner somebody yeah so if you
bring somebody
oh you if you leverage up someone else's
experience sure then you could start off
doing that you could but you can't do it
by yourself not just it's madness if you
if you you always want to start small
why there and then and then build up
unless of course you probably someone
you trust a proper partner that's fully
involved they're not just giving you one
hour a week or one hour a month yeah if
they're fully part of their dealing in
their a part time in it then you get to
really learn off the back of their
experience so you got this big building
and you think this is the best way to
make money off off buildings rather than
small properties everywhere this is
where I want to go I don't just want to
control I want to actually own what
happened next
so I guess it was really about finding
my next deal so yes I quickly realized
that ownership so at the end of the
lease the landlord can take it back I
lose on that potential income source and
also I'm not paying down and you get
potentially if it's a repayment I don't
get to pen on a debt even if it's an
interest-only I don't get to benefit
from any capital appreciation if I
improve the rents and improve the
profitability of the property I increase
that net operating income that net rent
so then the value of the building
increases I don't get the benefit of
course I'm trying to sell so it was
really about me now going out to look
for site so I went to I was basically
open to development sites I had a
viewing of a property that someone and
I'm not got in touch of us about leasing
the property strangely we didn't really
advertise that thing while and got in
touch with us about this property that
he was converting into a student
accommodation because God beds
yeah I said can you come out I need
someone to I need a company to leave the
whole thing I'm soft go and have a look
and as I was there I looked out the
window of that building I saw another
building next
oh that's nice and I said who owns that
well we start building there and he said
I was just someone else but I'm gonna
buy that and I'm gonna develop on it and
I thought we'll see and so I went off
and found the owner of that building
next door he said he was gonna buy one
day and basically deal with that owner
to allow me some time to get planning
permission and then buy it so originally
I was meant to do an option agreement
which is where you have exclusive
exclusivity for a certain period of time
in order to allow you to buy the
property but it's not the obligation to
buy the property and so original was
meant to be that last minute he changed
it and said no I don't an option
agreement I want you to be tithing to
the purchase you want he wants to delay
the sale yeah so we want he want us to
be kept tied in rotten creational
contract so we agreed to that
it was rune SBV agreed to that and click
on conditional purchase that has
exchanged with delayed completion for a
year and during that year I got planning
permission he took 10 months to get
planning permission on that I think you
were very glad when you got planning oh
it's gonna buy it it was more of a yeah
definitely happy but it was more of a I
guess it was more of a relief yeah a lot
of time and effort and when he's gone
into it yeah so you didn't put down a
penny
well maybe a penny but you didn't put
down and eat how much did you put down
to secure the option the first bites
you've got the legal but the option fee
was agreed at five grand
okay option fee in last minute he said
no I want it to be unconditional so I
said all right that so that's five grand
for the exchange yeah
Soniya exchange for five grand and comes
off the price comes off the purchase
price and then the purchase price is 400
K okay and delayed completion for a year
so you okay so you put on five thousand
pound and then in 12 month time you've
got to put down 395 and then they won't
it yeah and then in that 12 months
you've got planning permission to turn
it into what it's doing 60 originally
got planning permission for outline
panel permission for 58 flats and it's
since then we've done some changes it so
the GD V so the GDP growth development
value of the future development
is well when it was 58 class 2a circuit
six meal now it's 68 flats as we did
some changes and amendments and stuff
it's seven mill but the value of the
land itself just with the planks yeah
and it's one point two okay so you got a
pretty good deal there good deal good
deal but then it took some risk didn't
it yeah because if you have a planning
permission for it then they need a kind
of stock either been stuffed lost again
bigger bigger reward so so okay so four
hundred thousand then it was worth 1.2
which you got the planning permission
and then once you it actually did the
conversion how much that cost that's
ongoing so that it just your building
that that was so us but we've demolished
it now yeah so it's a new build building
that's going there on that side so
that's a that's in the process we're
just about to commence animation
oh we've been really proud of that half
of that property yeah proud proud of the
tool yeah I mean sit it's it's nice it
to do the leg work yourself and pull it
off and find it yourself
how many development deals have you done
then so that's obviously a massive one
that's the that's the first bit I've
done I mean it's smaller development
I've done it unlike houses and structure
works you know version and stuff that
big one is my first big one scared about
that one or you relieved is it's all
good always a still risk the main risk
is pretty much we've done ground
investigation now so the building's been
demolished we don't we've had to do a
about to get every game to check the
ground conditions and check it for any
contamination it's come back fine so
that's where the main risk is in the
ground so it's okay
so it's fine I'm not - now the main risk
is really about any potential
construction delays yeah increasing
costs how you finance in that deal Bank
so the Bank of funding have a percentage
of the refurb less a new-build
the bank's funding circuit eighty eighty
percent yeah of the cons what were you
getting that 20 percent bump myself and
my partner's my one of my partner
so fortunately when he came time to
complete on that land my partner
probably the money for the loan
fortunately so that that was pretty
and so generally you can get these days
at least with the funding you can get
usually 100% of development and build
cost funded if you own the land
I'm encumbered which it was it was more
cash yeah so we were able to fund 100%
of the deal but in terms of the total
cost of everything it's about 80% that
the bank comes in at yeah yes hollinger
cost what do you think the development
will be on that then how much will you
have to put down well obviously the top
lane for most of it but yeah a total
development devote total development
cost four and a half million okay which
is four and a half million plus four
hundred grand but then if it's got an N
value of seven million
you've become a multi-millionaire just
off of that one deal
pot yeah so yes for MUC for me because I
own that part of that deal it would be a
multi-millionaire but technically
million a off the deal yeah there's
there's seven figures in it so it's a
good deal yeah but it's a lot of risky
there's a lot of problems that come of
it beforehand there's a lot of your
grounds you learn those after this one
name yeah I've got a member student
accommodation deals I've got a volume
hanley which is a site that took me 18
months to get planning on that's gone
for how many months 18 18 18 it took a
very long time to get planning on that
these things take time
earnest it's very very long-winded
process the planning process is horrid
as I'm pretty sure it's not a good
process it's quite long-winded is quite
young a lot of red tape about
bureaucratic so what's the long-term
plan I know you want to be a billionaire
yeah what you want to be a billionaire
why it's not just about challenging
myself I don't I don't I don't go around
saying I want to be a billionaire I'm
gonna be a billionaire because number
one I do believe it and its internal I
just don't I don't put it out there
because generally because I don't want
to feed up any bad vibes if someone
looks
funny angles and things you can see that
funny-looking hello is look at you funny
I go then that's not the kind of energy
you want to feed over they'll look at
you funny just because just cuz of the
bills minute but fastest said to someone
oh I want to be a millionaire I'm gonna
be a millionaire and and they don't know
who I am or what I've done or what I'm
doing
they probably think you're funny then if
they did a bit of research of oh is that
what you're working on yeah then it
would seem a bit more implausible but
then to go from where I am now to go to
I mean it's a big jump it's a massive
job phione so my current pipeline now is
about 100 100 million pounds in deals
that they're worth once they're all
built and developed out they'll be worth
100 million so my share of that is maybe
you know 15 to 20 million mmm so it's to
then jump a billion yeah but you know
you know that you know the power the
compound effect this is it you're 30
years old yeah so I think a lot of time
adds up but it's about so for me it's
internal and why I want to be I don't so
I don't really go around saying it or
but why I want to do it some more about
pushing myself you know while I push my
push my push my limits you know why I
want to be a billionaire I want to be a
billionaire because of here all become
in becoming a billionaire as in your
mind set the level of thinking
everything everything but connections
one grows no growth yeah it's not about
the billion and what if you what if you
won it on some kind of crazy you're then
that then I've give it away only
interested in that it's not about the
billion for me it's about the journey to
it yeah even the journey the process
mm-hmm it's about the process of who you
become that's why I want to be a
millionaire now I'm a very different
person to what I was ten years ago
yeah because I've grown and my
capacities bigger hmm and I think in
pursuit of a god billion and who do you
think that no you're a millionaire and
that's sort of like a tick do you think
do you think it's a massive jump to
billionaire yes if a baby baby lose a
thousand me
massive needs a massive it's not the
same it so to me when someone saves him
this purse is oh it doesn't really mean
it a millionaire
maybe you should know exactly I'm in the
middle I for many years I'm a Multi
multi multimillionaire it doesn't mean
that damn thing like that do you know
what it doesn't mean a damn thing I'll
tell you why because 100 years ago or
even 30 years ago because money shrinks
yeah you'd be a millionaire was a big
deal but because a million pounds is
worth less but it starts the same ring
to it
actually if you own a house in London
with no mortgage you're probably a
millionaire
I mean that's not a big deal anymore but
I think for me as I it's not just it's
because the people I tend to be around
it sort of yeah everyone's sort of in
that position not for me cuz I'm a
trainer okay so I'm spending I spend a
lot of time people but are just starting
out okay that makes but then most of
which people but then the people I'm
working him say on my joint ventures if
I'm bringing in someone working we're
all in a certain position yeah tend to
be because they're putting a lot of
money but you know what most rich people
hide away and that's why I'm so glad to
see you coming on the show and put
yourself out there because most people
when they get to a certain level of
success they then hide yeah if they
don't want they don't want other people
to number one learn what they're doing
and number two they don't want to be
hated on same was between you said I
don't want to say I want to be a busy
next people gonna hang on me people
gonna look at me funny say but that's
more for their energy I don't know I
don't want someone to I went to this
event a few months back it was a I'm one
of the name of the event yeah wasn't an
event it was like a what you call it
I'll say okay it's a KPI key person of
influence oh yeah I went to they had
this little seminar they had this I've
read the book a really good book by the
way key person of influence so I went to
isn't it all talk that they do yeah and
then they have this little class and so
it's that class and they would go around
asking everybody their goals and I'm
never gonna lie so they came to me I
said what's your goals for the next ten
years or whatever they said I was like X
billion pound portfolio some of it
but everyone looked at me like and I
want to make it worse I have my
sunglasses on because I had to
conjunctivitis so my eyes are really
holy oh yeah so I'm on sunglasses I'm
sitting there I'm going yet might put
billion and then look at me like this
yeah but I'm never gonna lie so I think
they can penalize it yeah exactly the
thing is it's easy to it's easy to be
misconstrued for someone that's just a
big talker yeah exactly
that's that's what they're getting it
for me is to get in that if you get that
those negative for me it's negative by
this someone who looks at you like
what's wrong with this guy and I don't
have to balance of me because that I
don't internalize that sort of energy
that make sense yeah so I like to
position myself and I'm just used to
that now you're used to it you start it
off I just bounced out
under smile I smile but at the end of
the day you got a you've got a project
you're working on now it's gonna be
worth four seven million my castle is
going to have six million well so you
beat me by a million just just the
middle but then that's conservative so
we'll see you see which one is it with
the higher value but they're really
really proud of you man I'm really
pleased forty-four you've been doing
I've loved following you journey also
you have a YouTube channel
yeah Antony Laval so you guys need to
check him out on YouTube thanks for
coming into the office I'm cheering you
on
thank you
[Music]